what are you supposed to give a [__]
about according to you
is it different for each person or are
there rules people can kind of follow to
figure it out
uh i i intentionally don't answer that
question
because i i don't feel it's right for me
to impose my values on
any of my readers um i do
simply at times in the book i offer kind
of what i've discovered
is better or worse to give a [__] about
for myself
um and i do provide i'm going to harass
you about that in a minute or two
so i thought i'd warn you about that so
you can prepare
for the war no problem
i i do lay out i think some principles
that i i
generally i think find to be useful you
know so so generally
it's more it's more useful to focus on
um
kind of what i i for uh it's not the
most sophisticated
uh terms but internal values versus
external about you know so focus on
things that
occur inside of you focus on your own
integrity
focus on your own honesty these are
things that you experience
internally versus say um you know
things that you experience externally
external markers of validation
um what would that be like fame is that
an example
money yeah so money social media
followers things like that
having a nice car um you know there's
nothing wrong with those but
it it's kind of it's similar to the
the discussion we were having earlier
like it's we all like money we all like
having nice things but there needs to be
uh you can't only value those things
like you have to have a balance of
kind of more internally driven uh
things that you care about so i do think
that you impose your values on your
readers
and but i actually think well okay i'm
going to make two observations the first
is that
i think that apologizing for that is the
most predictable thing that a millennial
could possibly do
because i think your generation and
perhaps even more the generation younger
than you
what they've been taught above all else
is that the cardinal mor
moral sin is to judge be judgmental
right to be discriminating but that's
absolutely foolish and you actually make
a case for that because you say that one
of the most important things that you
can do
and by you you mean you but you also
mean other people
is to say no and that as soon as you
value one thing which you need to do and
hopefully the proper thing
you're saying no to a very large number
of other things
and so this is why the the the stance of
of of of the idea that you can raise
being non-judgmental to the level of a
higher moral virtue is definitely wrong
if your claim is correct that your
emotional
state depends on your value structure
and it's more important than anything
else to get your value structure
straight
and if you have a value structure you
have to say yes to some
things and no to others then you
immediately admit that there's a value
hierarchy and there's some things at the
top and some things at the bottom
and i think one of the real strengths of
your book is that
you at least begin to do that and and
and i think you do it explicitly
so you say quite straightforwardly that
there are five things that you've
discovered that are
of general utility that you've found of
general utility and
you don't say that you're certain that
you're 100
right about those five things but you
certainly make the claim that
the reader should take them seriously
and that they've been useful to you
and that was taking responsibility and
you do a very careful job of
distinguishing that from accepting
universal fault
which is a good good piece of
intellectual exercise because it's
necessary to take responsibility and to
discriminate that from assuming
universal fault you can get cancer
and it's not necessarily your fault in
fact it probably isn't
but you still have to take
responsibility for it or it will or
or or suffer the consequences you
talk about the necessity to accept and
cultivate the ability to tolerate to
accept uncertainty and to cultivate the
ability to tolerate it
you talk about um learning to appreciate
failure you talk about rejection we
already mentioned that and the ability
to say no
and the necessity of saying no and and
perhaps the unapologetic necessity of
saying no
and you also uh
you make that concrete in some sense
because you talk about for example
that you learned as you transition from
your 20s to your 30s that
saying no to an entire
smorgasbord let's say of sexual
possibilities
was worthwhile because you found
something deeper in the commitment to a
single person
and that's a form of sacrifice you talk
about sacrifice in your second book and
um you know you made a sacrifice and
sacrifices are actually worthwhile
and then you talk about contemplation of
your own mortality as a way of
discriminating between what's important
and what isn't and so
and then in your second book you talk
about both nietzsche and kant in some
detail and
both of them were striving for for the
apprehension of something approximating
a universal morality
and so i can see that and you also
mentioned ernest becker
you know and and and um you know becker
believed that all right you got me
what do you say you got me well what
yeah
you totally no you you are right it's
funny because
so now now i'm kind of doing like a
a check of of of my because you are
right you are correct
um i think
and it's and i gave you i'm going to
admit here i gave you guys the stock
answer
there you know when so that's a
dangerous thing to do
i i know especially with you guys but
you know i've been asked a million times
people like oh so what should we give a
[__] about and
my my de facto answer has always been
like well it's not my place to tell
people exactly what their values
[__]
that's definitely not true that's
exactly what you're trying to do
now when 13 million people are listening
i think the reason you get away with it
is because you're trying to do it for
yourself too you're not preaching
and you're kind of inferring right you
say this is what worked for me
but it could work for you right yeah and
let me well let me present some context
to this which i think can
can be helpful um you know my my
background
is straight up just the self-help world
and
generally in the self-help world values
are just shoved down your throat you
know you're supposed to want
then the fancy car you're supposed to
want the perfect marriage you're
supposed to want to be happy and live
happily ever after you know it's like
these are the things that
um are taken for granted at page one and
so
you know i when i wrote subtle art i
went through pains to kind of
be contrarian a lot of ways to what a
typical self-help book
is and so one of those ways was i don't
want to
explicitly ram values down people's
throats but i agree with you
that the overarching project of the book
is yes i am i am imposing
um even if if i don't come out and say
it like
this is what you should give a [__]
about it it's
the way i've constructed the book and
particularly the second book the the
book the second book is much more
striving for
um striving for some sort of
solid structure by the way yeah
just so everybody knows well you you
hooked yourself into this
project as soon as you made that initial
discovery like you made a
quite a profound discovery in my
estimation which was that
values regulate emotion
so then then as soon as you make that
discovery
you're stuck with a question which is
okay then what are the appropriate
values that make me happy
well or or or even well
if it's not happy it's some other metric
you know because you can also question
whether or not happy is the right
ultimate development i like happiness i
know you you're like it's not about
being happy but
well it beats the hell out of being
miserable if happiness comes along you
should be bloody
happy that it's like lit on you on your
stem
for a while yeah yeah but it's
yeah and then as soon as you get into
that question it's turtles all the way
down right like it's
that's that's that takes you into
um you know kind of staring into the
void so to speak which
you talk about in your work quite a bit
of of you know how there's
you have to you have to take on the
responsibility to create
some something that's meaningful in your
life yes or to discover it
that's one of the weaknesses of
nietzsche i think i mean i'm a great
admirer of nietzsche and
he he i've never read anyone who could
think with his much glittering
brilliance as nietzsche and
he's very dangerous to read because he's
so unbelievably intelligent he'll take
everything you know apart sometimes with
a sentence
he said once he was bragging in a sort
of
self-deprecatory manner in some sense i
mean he never sold any books and
so he was sort of bragging to himself i
suppose he said
i can say in a sentence what it takes
other people an entire book to say
what they can't say in an entire book
that actually happens to be true
nietzsche could in fact do that
and he believed that we could create our
own values but that's wrong
we can't create our own values we can
discover them
and we can co-create them but you know
and you you know this in your book as
well it comes out again
implicitly um you wouldn't be able to
violate your conscience if you could
create your own values
right violate your conscience yeah
because your conscience you'll you'll
lower this for me a little bit you'll do
you you'll do something that your
conscience objects to
okay okay if you were fully capable of
creating your own values
your conscience would never object you
would just go along with what you'd
proposed
like if we were the sorts of creatures
that could do that but what we find very
rapidly is
we try very hard to impose our own
values
and then we then it fails we're not
satisfied by what we're pursuing or we
become extremely guilty or become
ashamed or we're hurt or we hurt other
people and sometimes
sometimes that doesn't mean we're wrong
but most often it does
and so yeah this this
and and you your your search for bedrock
i think is
and and perhaps the fact that you never
do come to any
final conclusion is definitely at least
in my opinion
so maybe not definitely but in my
opinion
a large part of the reason why your
books are attractive you know the
millennials
you you know you talk about the consumer
literature that shows that people who
have an infinite variety of choices
are less happy than people who only have
one or two
and you mentioned at the beginning of
this discussion that the millennial
generation that you're a part of
suffered in some sense because they they
weren't deprived enough and had too many
choices
the advantage to being deprived is that
it's obvious what to do
like if you're starving then you eat
there's no question but if you have
enough to eat and you have enough
shelter and you have enough information
maybe not as much as you could have but
enough
it starts to become difficult to decide
what to do
and then you have another problem which
is that you can't decide what to do
yeah and and then you have to start to
investigate value
and that that seems to me even from your
autobiographical comments seem to be
what happened with you
and obviously so many other people
absolutely